dude I got gerelds of rivia in this pack
I got Gerald of rivia right there look
at him I got ghoul I got Griffin Griffin
got five attack Mike what about your
pack your pen with a monster pack oh so
I got the bad guys sweet yeah down full
pot you know if they don't refer look
how many vendors I went to in special
quests I did Dennis Cranmer don't recall
meeting him throughout the witcher 3 but
Dennis Cranmer he looks I think he's a
dwarf I got seems like a lot easier than
in game where you have to it yep
collecting one by one clear whether I
did not clear whether sword fight but
goblin for these how much gwent did you
play in the witcher 3 the bare minimum
loads yeah it was good great i just i'd
rather be killing ghouls and stuff
really yeah then collecting a sick fiend
or mahakam on feet or mahaa c'mon this
is the this is the the boxed copy of The
Witcher threes and expansion pack hearts
of stone which I love because you
literally open up the box and then
inside is a download code for the game I
was going to say so the expansion pack
is not actually a game it's now the card
card game that that's the new expansion
bag yeah yep there's a piece of card
here with the code on it which I can't
show you folks and then you basically
have a thing that has a bunch of
Quentin's to full packs it's got the i
guess the monster set and i forget the
name of what you call this the main set
whatever it's called starter deck yeah
whatever i forgot torrential rain
torrential rain but apparently in the
Northern Kingdom Spears fall when it
rains as well yes I've got to be careful
Cloudy with it look at these names I
love this look at all this like stuff
for like Gwen's it's like so confident
my favorite thing is that they give you
two packs because if they give you one
you'd have to find someone else who also
bought the bucs tix about your bike and
you can easily divvy these up into like
two people like you could chop this pack
and a half easy and still have an
absolutely massive set and it will then
even though this is like a physical
version that you can play they've said
before that they don't want to turn this
into its own game yeah mostly because
like some of these rare cards make
your debt kind of Opie yeah I know
Garrett of Rivia has like something
stupid like 16 so like that's like
that's that's that's ridiculous EOP
we're not here to talk about real-world
grunts there's more to this expansion
his wins there is the expansion also
comes with a video game and we played a
bunch of hearty stone last week
hearthstone hearts no not hearthstone
not hearthstone on a heart of stone
heart of startups I know look I know
it's a card game and it says hearts and
stone on us it's not art the hearts of
stone in their expansion magic gathering
yes much another go gathering of the
magics oh god damage yeah they probably
should have thought about actually but
we played some hard to stone last week
yeah we pay for me to three hours yeah
what was interesting was that we sort of
split during our time doing it at before
I talk about the weird stuff that I saw
that there we have no beer all off and
tell me about your experience what do
you think of hearts of stuff I liked it
a lot actually but we played about yeah
like you said 23 hours about what's ten
our total expansion they said but again
it's a big world so you'll probably be
wandering off the beaten path once in a
while but basically you just initiated
by going to a bulletin board where they
have this Witcher contract for like the
hunt a beast down and you keep hearing
about it and you end up going to the
sewers as you could see here and you
know Carol being himself is ready for to
kill something and so was I and in fact
what I liked about this boss fight on a
there was a couple more right off the
bat I felt like I think I did three in
the first two hours yeah and they were
all interesting and I played this one on
hard mode and barely figured it out and
after the sort of that it's a massive
well let's not say it for this boy is
actually it's a cool boss it definitely
you have to fight it differently than
you might just like a regular cool it's
it's not it doesn't fall into those
categories at the old ones did just like
a ghoul or a drowner or flying beast
thing yeah this is totally knew it was
it was tough actually I died once hmm I
think I played on the normal difficulty
yeah I mean I just about did I did it on
hard and I just and I did it there's
this pick up after the main games finish
there is this some kind of in between so
this picks up you have to be used level
he recommended around most of the bosses
why was our most of the enemies I was
fighting were like 30 to 33 and by the
time i was finna it was signed coop
doors 34 35 a couple of hours into it
and so it's that you can go into it at
any stage but you'll never be able to
complete that early mission unless
you're that's like almost like the like
difficulty gauge they have and in fact
later on i had story stuff happen which
definitely happened later in the game
referred to so it's like built into it
basically so you need to be around 30 or
so and like in the last third of the
game for instance so this is also the
part i did ok you saw this part no just
like the ghost thing yeah so old geared
von ever at keys the guy who originally
gives you the quest he says he gives you
like these two seemingly mundane
objectives yes you did one i did the
other your sounded way cooler although
mine was pretty entertaining it's like
the crux of this is that you have to
complete a certain for some reason if to
complete a list of things for this guy
and what's pretty cool about is they all
sound like boring fetch quest it's like
take yet my brother out for a night on
the town you're like seriously like you
he could just as easily go to a tavern
by himself yank alone but as it turns
out that's a little more complicated
again I don't it's very story heavy so I
want to spoil it yet but trust me it's
it's a lot more entertaining that it's
very well set up actually and then you
did one as well yeah I did one which
again I don't want to get into the
nitty-gritty of it because it was
certainly fun to find out but it
basically the mission that I took on was
essentially a heist from Grand Theft
Auto 5 where I needed to get inside of a
building and I was sent on a bunch of
missions to get the crew to do so so
there was a note there was a way to get
into this building but I needed to have
like a you know the explosive expert and
it gave me like details on these two
rich characters which I could one of
which I could pick up again I also
needed to have like I saw that an
infiltration expert and there was like
this cool gymnastic other person just
like troll or dwarf or something like it
also am higher so like immediately went
okay this is all you have to do go out
and find these people and in the limited
time we had I went and find two of them
and to try and like see what they were
like and then they have these very inch
thing like unique moments happen to them
so were you playing with it like did
they like play along with you and you
got to see how their abilities kind of
would help you in battle or in the
culmination of this vise yeah you had to
kind of convince them to come with you
and some of them were you know we're
having their own problems and maybe you
need to help or like I had one who was
freaking out because he had a domestic
problem at home let us say and then I
think you could probably talk about of
us but I bet living crap out of him
stats and he decided to work for me so
like it felt like a really clever setup
and also there was earlier in it there
was a part where I was basically in an
auction and because I was a had a I
guess a an account that said their
projects had given to us which had lots
of money on us I basically outbid
everyone but like there was all these
interesting unique dialogue things that
happened during the auction that could
let you know information about the stuff
that was on operon you weren't even
there for the oxygen reader for
committee different reason but it was
like it's just everything about what I
played over the first a couple of hours
of this felt rich felt like really
interesting boss fights really unique
situations I didn't see during my time
playing Wild Hunt and I really like the
setup of the main quest with with that
antagonist as well yeah Von Erich geared
yeah essentially hey Carter yeah he was
we can't talk about so much oh my god
it's so good we only played like a fifth
of this expansion yeah I initially we
had talked on the lobby a week or two
ago about when we're gonna get into this
and i originally said maybe like early
next year they did for the next
expansion but now that i played it I
it's definitely on my list of things I
want to play among like you know those
big triple I games coming out this fall
because essentially what you did was
like Gerald 11 or like it was like it
was like a the height this fantasy
setting I kind of went to a wedding and
it was like a sitcom but both seen mind
was entertaining as well when now I
really just want to see the heist and
then there's that other question neither
of us really went too far into that yeah
there's more stuff I also did a sigh
quest that was optional that was in this
expansion pack which was pretty
interesting as well yeah yeah this girl
kept calling me puss peepers probably
because I cats eyes or whatever chic
have called me post Peter peepers and
girls was not happy with it and that was
really cool and then there's a bunch of
other stuff as well there's new
abilities a lot of
we didn't unlock because they kind of
gave us all the points but we just sort
of hurriedly put them all in and and
there's a couple of new yeah special
magic abilities new items as well quite
a lot in there and we met Shawnee for
the first time yes three yeah core
character which have I guess fans of the
series will remember and she seems very
interesting I liked your explanation on
the video she's kind of smarter than
gerelds yeah like very much so and like
it's kind of she has a humility tourist
so she kind of talks down to him but not
in there like a nun that she's not
looking down I'm she's just trying to
like ease him through it which is kind
of it's an interesting dynamic I think
yeah the dialogue is awesome especially
because the brother of Von Erich that
you bring out for the night she joins
you at certain cordially so it's just
her brother being really crass and crude
and like just like kind of like hitting
on her the entire time and gerelds kind
of like all right just chill out stop
being a jerk and then but she just the
whole time doesn't even give him the
time of day she doesn't care she just
ignores it but yeah you sense a girl's
kind of picking up on the fact that he's
way outpaced by her in terms of
intelligence so she kind of takes it
easy on him in terms of verbal back and
forth which is kind of funny to see him
not the boss of the conversation yeah
I'm definitely gonna jump in earlier to
this as well I think based on I'm
playing that I'm powering through my
girl to the moment I Justin you played a
little bit of The Witcher 3 if they
liked I got about 10 15 hours through it
i think it's interesting you guys
mentioned like it's gonna be such a busy
holiday yeah but you're still drawn into
this world like there's both enough
content and that it's interesting enough
that you want to go back into the
witcher 3 and I'm like oh I'm still I
still have to finish the witcher 3 this
is going to be a busy end of the year
because we also have a lot of big RPGs
yep fallout 4 like fallout 4 on itself
like that's just an intimidating thing
to think about big time at sash october
13th so not too far to wait and that's
sort of 25 book mark depending if you're
buying an online or at retail yeah so
let us know what you think are you gonna
pick it up are you gonna pick up this
hot physical heart stone is there a
special edition or is that every edition
of the game well you can buy digitally
and it doesn't have this oh so but if
you buy this so I imagine it's probably
cost a little bit more but you had no
disc included it says right in the bar
writing the top pc download only
contains hearts of stone download code
to Gwent cards 154 cards in total I with
game tokens so yeah you're essentially
just reorder buying this what's his hey
reordain sure some elf Reardon is it
Reardon may that's an Irish name come on
you should not be like Marty my middle
names Irish Gaelic is what is it Rouen
are you a any Ruane ruinous Americans
say oh there's those Americans dastardly
Americans oh yes American for more weird
Gaelic surnames check out witcher 3 wild
hunt hearts of stone coming like i said
october 13 and let us know if you're
gonna pick it up let's know it's gonna
pick up the weird guenter person that so
if you're going to plague went with your
friends in the comments below